You just saw one type of dependent samples t-test, where we test out and
measure samples from two different populations. In the case of the last
example, the populations were the number of errors made typing the 20-word text
message within 30 seconds on each keyboard configuration. This is called the
repeated measures design. And the null hypothesis, is that these two population
means will be the same. Before we finish this lesson, I'll tell you about two
other types of dependent samples t-tests. One is a longitudinal design, where
we measure a variable at one point in time and then we measure the same
variable for the same sample at a later point in time. And we want to know if
there's a significant difference between the variable at time 1 and time 2. So
the null hypothesis will be exactly the same symbolically as for repeated
measures design. Only with this design we're putting a lot of time in between
measuring the variables. And then, a third type of dependent sample's design is
a pretest posttest, where we measure a variable, implement some kind of
treatment, and then measure the same variable for the same sample after the
treatment to see if there was a significant effect due to the treatment. Again,
the null hypothesis is the same, that the variable won't significantly change
before the treatment and after the treatment. You'll see examples of these two
types of designs in problem set 10. Great job. T-tests are pretty complicated,
so now dive deeper with Dr. Laraway. He's going to go into more detail on these
concepts and then go through a full one sample t-test so you can get a lot of
practice and really understand how to use these.